woman in New York City heard me say the
words I don't like the WNBA now I didn't
say I don't respect it I didn't say I
didn't want my daughter to do it I
didn't even say I don't like people that
that like it and this woman went from
enjoying me
to arms crossed
shaking her head in disgust and her and
her girlfriend they looked at me as if
to say like why Paul why because it's
women typical misogynist because has no
idea that I have a little girl at home
that I take to hockey that I take to
flag football that I take to soccer this
woman just heard me say the words I
don't like the WNBA and in that moment
turned me into a misogynistic piece of
guys I don't like the WNBA because
it stinks that's why I don't
like it all right I don't like the WNBA
because I just watched an NBA game where
a guy dunks from the foul line while
shoving his nuts down another man's
throat okay
sorry if that's more entertaining than
some chick using all her might to hoist
up a rainbow three and a half empty
Arena at an Indian Casino
[Applause]